hey hey so welcome everybody to today's
panel on should I stay or should I go
how to know when it's time for a career
transition I'm Rachel I am a program
coordinator and a career adviser at
Udacity so I have gotten to work with a
number of our graduates helping them
through a career transition including
two of our panel guests today I'm joined
by Christine Chang who is a who's
currently a technical writer / iOS
developer at app dynamics Thomas Hughes
who is a data scientist at Amazon and
last but not least either the vet C who
is a software engineer and machine
learning engineer on our AI team here at
Udacity so if any of you guys have gone
through a career transition it's pretty
difficult to kind of know when and how
to kind of navigate the ropes and to
decide how to pull the trigger and when
and kind of how to get started on it so
we're gonna be kind of talking about all
of that today and I'd like to let my
guest kind of introduce themselves a
little bit and then we'll get started hi
I'm Christine as Rachel mentioned I'm a
technical writer and so that means for
currently I work with engineers to write
user guides that help people install
configure and administer enterprise
software and last year I completed the
iOS nano degree so I'm currently in the
process of transitioning into a career
in iOS development hi I'm Thomas I'm
currently a data scientist with with
Amazon actually with AWS and I used to
be a professor of political philosophy
so it was a bit of a career change for
me but I've sort of these days I do
consulting with AWS so major enterprise
customers want help with machine
learning because they know they need it
but have no idea what they're doing so
they come to my team and we kind of do
proof-of-concept sort of work for them
I'm Ethan and I work at Udacity
Rachel mentioned my think we're looking
at career transitions today so my
transition was I went from being a
college dropout to to a QA analyst and
then eventually its software engineer
for a long time and then more recently
made a transition into the machine
learning field before I came to work it
Udacity yeah and I even went under when
a Korean to just transition myself not
necessarily by choice because my I lost
my job
and was kind of forced into it but I to
be perfectly honest would not have it
any other way
I love what I do now this is definitely
not where I saw my career going but it's
something I kind of discovered that I
was passionate about and like just find
a lot of joy in what I do and so that's
been great so what how we're going to
structure this is I'm gonna ask there's
gonna be questions that I have for each
of our guests um and we're gonna do kind
of a group conversation and then also
I'd really like everybody if you there's
questions you'd like to ask of us we are
gonna have a Q&A session at the end so
maybe think about some things you'd like
to ask of the group and we'll definitely
make time for that okay so to get
started
Christine I kind of wanted to know a
little bit more about what drove your
transition specifically and how you
because you are currently in it right
now right it's something you are right
now going through what has been your
approach so what has been how how have
you approached it what have you done and
and how's it going yeah so I first got
into iOS development because I had
randomly met like this iOS developer who
was super passionate about poke about
mobile development he was just like
overflowing with enthusiasm about it and
so that's how I started looking into it
and what got me really interested in
mobile development is like the really
interesting challenges that mobile
design poses because you're forced to
kind of fit a lot of functionality into
a small screen and so that's kind of
like what drove my curiosity and also
since I've been working as a technical
writer even though I really enjoy the
writing aspect I always felt like I
wanted to be closer to the product and
so I think doing some sort of develop
software development would allow me to
do that and in terms of approaching my
career transition I obviously applied to
a lot of jobs
and I also started an iOS engineering
blog which I keep up-to-date fairly
regularly so I post regularly to my blog
and it's helped me a lot in just like
solidifying my software foundations and
also just kind of proving to hiring
managers and recruiters that you know
I'm capable of those skills and that I'm
you know I have a solid foundation in
addition to that I've started working
part time on my company's iOS app and so
that's given me a lot of kind of
real-world experience in mobile
development so that's also kind of a
stepping stone that I've taken in
transitioning full-time and when we were
working together on your job search one
of the other things that I know you were
you put a lot of effort into was your
own app and getting that published so
can you talk a little bit about what
that experience was like and how that
also lend like prompted it like helped
your job search along - yeah so I
created an app called runner's air trek
it's essentially an air quality app
tailored to runners so depending on the
air quality of the city that you're
running in ill give you advice on like
your running routine so whether or not
it's safe to run outside or if it's
better to run on a treadmill and
throughout that process I think the two
biggest things that that prot me was the
importance of perseverance and reading
API documentation and software
development I think like a lot of people
don't associate software development
with reading but if you really want to
develop something with good practices
and not get stuck like in the same Rock
right it's a lot of reading and that's
something that I learned just trying to
build an app from scratch what I think
is very valuable mm-hmm and I'm sure
that that's also had a big impact on
your job search and your ability to kind
of talk to companies yeah I'm gonna sell
your experience and be able to talk
about like everything you've done and
why you're a good fit now yeah they just
definitely having an app on the App
Store gives you a lot more street cred
you know recruiters and hire managers
are more inclined to talk to you if you
know they can see something tangible
that you've already done especially if
you don't have any prior work experience
on your resume yeah great thank you
so Thomas your
next you ready I'm ready so I you've had
a long history with career transitions
right so when we were talking and
preparing for this one of the things
that kind of stuck out to me was the
fact that the transition that you just
undertook was not even your first
transition so maybe you can give us a
little bit of context about like how
you've approached all of that right so
what's been kind of the driving force
behind that yeah that's that's actually
a great question so going into political
philosophy was actually the first
transition I made I I worked in tact
back in the 90s so back when the
internet was first becoming a commercial
sort of thing I actually was working for
the company that invented the internet
casino so I had some interesting
co-workers who were not quite on the
payroll but were on the payroll to kind
of manage things for us which was
interesting but what I found in when I
when I started to formalize my career in
tech I found at the time I was really
too focused on my tools and not enough
on interesting questions so I pivoted
very hard away from technology in the
early 2000s did got a PhD in political
science focused on political philosophy
taught for six years as a professor of
political philosophy and I don't know if
you know that market at all but turns
out philosophy market is horrible it's
it's not actually a great career
decision so something really interesting
started happening a few years ago which
is that the the machine learning AI data
science revolution just sort of took off
and that was really interesting to me
because it combined a couple things I
was interested in it combined technology
which I enjoyed but not when it was for
its own sake with really interesting
questions we started doing things like
self-driving cars we started doing
things like natural language processing
we started doing all sorts of bizarre
predictions I get I get the weirdest
questions now from my co-workers like I
got asked this morning did you ever have
a dog I want to do image recognition for
fleas on dogs this week and those are
just kind of fun questions so it was a
moment that I think is a very rare
moment where I saw
questions with with fun technology and I
saw a kind of opportunity for a career
transition there so yeah that's the the
long trajectory for me yeah and so how
how did you net like how did you
approach your job search from beginning
to end like what were some of your your
learnings and your your the directions
you took yeah that's that's another
great question because I was very
reckless in some ways when I
transitioned immediately from philosophy
to to data science I was just like I'm
gonna do my own startup I have no
experience I'm just gonna wing it and
get the experience along the way I've
got some friends in tech so I'll see if
they'll help me out and they said yes
and they got busy and didn't help me out
so like all startups it was mostly on me
which was surprisingly actually great
for the career move a lot of employers
really look highly upon the willingness
to do that in a lot of ways people are
wondering how do I get my experience
clock to start just making it up as you
go along counts for more than you'd
think so that was the first move I made
when when it failed like all startups do
or most startups do I was like okay
maybe I should like get some sort of
formal education so that's where Udacity
kind of came into the picture I I did
the machine learning nano degree and I
wanted to make sure I had my bases
covered really well which I felt like
the nano degree did a very good job of
and then I went on a formal job search I
was picked up by actually I was given
one offer that I ended up turning down
which I never thought I would turn down
a job offer which was surprising but
then I worked briefly with The Times of
India which was another thing I was not
expecting as Silicon Valley actually has
a data science lab for The Times of
India doing content recommendations so I
got picked up doing that for a while and
then really once you get your foot in
the door in data science opportunities
start knocking at your door pretty
regularly so I got called up by AWS and
they were like where we're interested
you seem to be doing interesting work
and I started there last October okay
yeah that's great and it was great to
work with you too on your job search
it's it with you Christine so even as a
college dropout
your parents were probably not very
happy with you at that time but you are
now in a good position and I feel like
you probably made the right choice at
that moment so maybe you can talk a
little bit about kind of going through
the uncomfortable feelings of like doing
what you feel is right even though it
might not be traditionally on paper the
best move yeah sure
well to be clear when I was in college I
was only there for a brief time for a
few months and I was majoring music and
so because it was free
I had a full ride to go if as long as I
played oboe in the band I could I could
stay there I you know I sort of felt
like I can do nearly anything that gave
me a long time to think about what what
do I really want to do and that same
freshman year I got my now wife and I
got engaged and and I've always sort of
treated you know what I want to do in
life is a kind of an optimization
problem and the you know part about do
we want to have kids do we want to be
able to like live in a house that's
bigger than a one-bedroom apartment was
pretty significant so like it was a very
pragmatic decision to say I know I don't
want to keep doing this I love music but
like this is this is not I don't want to
be under the stress of like having to
provide for a family that way long term
and both my father and my grandmother
had been software engineers also on
college and so it was actually like
perhaps a more natural path for me than
it might've been for people who didn't
have that that example but yeah I was my
parents' were quite disappointed and I
think only after they saw that like I
was never without a job even though I
really really wanted to do was like
going to software I was an accountant
for a while just to keep to pay things
while I learned and you know then got my
from the doors of QA analyst which is
not the job I wanted but was a good way
to like prove that I could do well at
whatever was put in front of me and then
it things just got easier from there
because like Thomas said once once you
have a little bit the opportunity to
keep coming or at least you know for
things that are demand right now yeah
when I think that's a really important
part of a career transition is sometimes
when you are making the change you kind
of have to start over right so you don't
always
land where you want to end up you
sometimes land where you need to begin
and so maybe you could talk a little bit
about how you you understood the fact
that as a QA analyst you would be given
the path towards growth and how you've
kind of gone from there and built your
career into where you are now
yeah I think what I saw was that lots of
people who are coming in the door and
we're getting picked up very easily had
some sort of formal credentialing but
those things were expensive they cost
them money and and at the time actually
felt like that's what most of what
formal education was I don't feel that
way now but at the time I felt like that
most college was essentially some sort
of like class signaling and that if you
could afford that then you could you
could have a nice job and but the I
think the idea that's there is like
there's some piece of external
validation that says you know this
person is not gonna be a total flake and
if you don't have come with that already
written from somebody else you're gonna
have to kind of write your own so I
think I saw that as being humbling
because I didn't see my statuses I did I
didn't want that to be my long term
career but at the same time like I was
getting I looked at it is I'm getting my
signal but I'm getting paid for it a
little and so I think that like look
look looked at in that light of you know
everything that I'm doing is is still a
stepping stone in the direction that I
want to go and that I can't just jump to
where I want to be made it easier and
actually I think the lot of that
happiness comes from like your
philosophical alignment if you spend a
lot of time I think that what you don't
want to do or how much you don't like
what you're doing right now then it's
probably heard to make much progress
yeah and that was all I mean it was a
long time ago there's a decade yeah okay
so now to the group I have some
questions for you so I want to know kind
of what were some of the challenges that
you faced in your transition process or
what you're currently going through
anything that was unexpected I think one
of the challenges which I'm sure a lot
of people face when they're
transitioning is just convincing hiring
hiring managers that you're worthy of
becoming you know a full-fledged
developer or data scientists when you
don't necessarily have that formal
background on your resume and so any I
know for me some of the ways that I
overcome that is you know by starting a
blog or like working on personal
projects and so something
was unexpected for me I guess is that
since I while I was applying to jobs I
didn't get too many hits and so my
mentality was kind of like I must be so
out of range of being qualified for even
like a junior position but when I
actually started talking to developers
that I met through conferences or
networking events I found that my
knowledge base was surprisingly actually
not too far off from theirs and that I
could actually carry a pretty in-depth
technical conversation with them without
feeling too far below so in a way it's
like almost as if like if you're feeling
really unqualified like if you actually
start talking to developers you might
find yourself becoming more confident
and more qualified I think status in a
job search should have no impact on like
how you see yourself and self-perception
and like what you would that are
applicable for it's completely unrelated
so I think that's an important call out
to make any other challenges that he any
of anybody else faced anything
unexpected I'll actually jump in and say
a related challenge but one I sort of
expected which was the the rate of
interviews and offers was right where I
expected which is like 10% on interviews
and less than 10% like a smaller
percentage of that of offers I expected
that it's still it's still pretty
demoralizing when you go weeks with
nothing and then eventually hearing
stuff so that that's that's something I
expected but it is definitely a
challenge something I wasn't expected
and I still deal with in interviews is
I'm terrible at whiteboard interviewing
and I've never gotten an offer from a
place where I've done a whiteboard
interview okay which tells you something
I'm working at AWS now and very quite
successful AWS but they never whiteboard
interviewed me there they gave me a
homework assignment which I can do very
very well on but stick me in front of a
whiteboard and ask me algorithm
questions and I I just can't do them
well and that's that's been a kind of
ongoing challenge with job searches in
general is quite a few places do
whiteboard interviews and that's
definitely challenging yeah you said
something else that I wanted to kind of
come back to you about how it's the
moral
about like the return the rate of in
turn on your job search and how that can
kind of just make anybody feel
discouraged so what were some of the
ways that you dealt with that I was
running a lot then so exercise actually
helps with mood I correspond to my first
major job search but when I got picked
up by The Times of India with training
for a half marathon so running fairly
long distances almost every day helped
give me something else to focus on
aside from just opening my email and
seeing nothing good point yeah yeah I
want to win I mentioned before that I
spent a long time sort of feeling like
the formal education was a huge waste of
time money and and I think that for the
first seven or eight years my career I
felt that way
I got I'd be able to get through a lot
of the engineering world by sort of just
having a high level understanding of
whatever it was I needed to know at the
time and just digging into the areas
that I needed to pick up in order to
understand the given subsystem or a
given you know architecture pattern and
when I tried to make the jump into
machine learning because I saw that it
was starting to be a common feature of
demand in in the industry
I started this wall of realizing that
like that top-down approach of just get
all the intuition and dig into what you
need later was not working for me and
that I didn't have the necessary mental
tools to be able to pick apart the rigor
that was at the edge of the currently
publish materials and so I had to go
back and learn how to learn because I
had never really done that and that's an
area where I think college might have
actually been very helpful and it was a
really really long arduous process like
I went back to to algebra and then went
from Khan Academy and out after calculus
and then and then spent some time in
Coursera going through more various
rigorous calculation linear algebra I
was doing like some of me had ratings
work there and eventually Udacity s
machine learning nano degree and that
period was very humbling like that
feeling of I've always been able to get
where I wanted to go by just pushing a
little farther in this direction and
there like there is no direction to step
from here that gets me there like I'm
gonna have to go down into the valley
and start again
to get to that other mountaintop and
like that was the moral icing because
there's no immediate return other and
eventually got to the point where sort
of enjoyed studying every day now now I
just do it out of habit I don't like I
need to anymore or that it's necessary
to keep pushing as much but like it
eventually became rewarding for its own
sake and that made it a lot easier to
carry on to the point where isn't just a
sort of natural part of my career yeah
well something that I feel like is a
thread between all three of you guys is
the whole lifelong learning and just
that education even when you have a job
doesn't stop and if you make it
something you enjoy versus something you
have to do it becomes a different you
have a different relationship with it so
I think that's a good another good call
out to make so final question for you
guys and then I'll open it up to the
audience for a few questions
I'm is if you were to give advice to
anybody what would be one piece of
advice you'd leave I would say utilize
professional social media so two things
one is LinkedIn premium I found is
really helpful because it gives you
access to a wider range of people's
profiles so whether or not you want to
reach out to recruiters or other
developers or people in the industry
you're looking to transition into and
also just seeing more profiles helps you
kind of gauge like a pattern and like
what maybe you can put on your profile
or on your resume to get from where you
are to where someone else that you've
seen like get to the place where someone
else's profile is and another app that I
found is useful is shaper which is like
tinder but for professional networking
and so if that's really useful for just
getting in touch with people in the
industry
you know they'll you can go out with to
the to coffee with them just one on one
get advice and tips great thank you so
that was shaper everybody if you're
wanting to write it down uh so I always
advise people to do a freelance project
like right now so the the barrier for
doing a freelance project is actually
really low the way I did this was I
called up a friend and said hey I'm
freelancing for you right now
and he said cool what are you doing and
I said I'm gonna I'm gonna do a data
it's model on some data no you don't
need this right now but if anyone asks
I'm freelancing for you and he's like
cool actually that might be useful and I
said yeah it's pro bono don't worry
about it
but as soon as I did that I was
professionally a data scientist doing
freelance work my experience clock was
ticking and it got me another project I
could put on my resume that I could talk
about during interviews and importantly
it wasn't just oh yeah I got bored one
day and did this I could say no I'm
doing this for a client so it made it
look like a much more professional sort
of relationship than just as a hobby so
I think that's that's very useful advice
that's great
I think the most significant pieces of
advice I would give in a career
transition is to recognize the symmetry
of the situation between you and an
employer I think that you often feel
like that any particular interaction you
have as a referendum on your value that
like when you go in apply that if you
were really good enough you would get
that job what's actually happening is
you're scared of not getting the job and
they're scared of someone hiring someone
who can't do the job and like you're
both scared that there's like you both
could could screw this up and so that
means that like every one of those
interactions there's some amount of like
randomness that's present in it and just
because you're good enough doesn't mean
you're gonna get that job and just
because you're not quite good enough yet
doesn't mean that you aren't going to
get that job and that each one of those
and you're like there are a lot of
things you can do one is to raise your
human capital by continuing to invest in
education can work on freelance projects
those sort of things but the other is to
realize that like as as your human
capital goes up your chance of any one
of those paying off for you is is rising
and so you just have to keep rolling the
dice then and not feel like that because
you were told no by one company or a
couple companies that that indicates
that you're below the bar you need to be
like it's it's not that deterministic
yeah great thank you guys so does
anybody have any questions that they'd
like to ask the panel yes and I think
Matt come in for you so one second
hi I'm Andy hi pail with Capgemini in
San Francisco based on your backgrounds
I would love to hear your thoughts on
the value of the diversity of your
experience on your current roles mmm
it's a great question I know for me I'll
talk a little bit about my background so
I was a
history major in college then went on to
get a masters in history graduated and
could not get a job in anything so I
started working as a program coordinator
in a higher education program that got
defunded and I just looked for anything
I could do so I became a recruiter
because I was good talking to people and
that snowballed into career advice but I
think that my background in terms of
program management and just knowing how
to research things through history and
understanding people in context for
situations and everything helped helps
me do my job today and I actually think
it's really valuable that I have a
non-traditional background because I'm
working with so many people who also
have a non-traditional background that's
a little bit of how I see my value
anybody else so my career so far has
been pretty writing oriented I did minor
and professional writing in college and
right after straight out of college I
started working as a technical writer
and I think that's helped me a lot like
the writing background has helped me a
lot in my progress as an iOS developer
just because I find that writing things
down and like writing about what you're
learning helps a lot and just
reinforcing concepts and also answering
questions that you had and we're gonna
ask someone else but in the process of
writing the question you kind of start
to formulate an answer and realize you
know like or you start to are in the
kinks out and I find that you know being
able to blog about technical concepts
has helped me grow a lot and just my
software development journey let's try
to make some time for a few other
questions anybody else want to ask
anything and if not there's no pressure
we will be available throughout the day
- I'll be in the Career Center and I
know my guests are going to be hanging
around for the day - so you can always
come up to us find us on LinkedIn even
and ask if the question is a little bit
feels a little personal
so any last takers okay
yeah yep thank you it seems like for
those of you who've made this career
transition from one to another the
vehicle that you've used most often is
just kind of start working in that field
and prove that you have at least have a
base knowledge of it is that correct
so like Miss Chang you did you started
writing blogs on iOS development you sir
sir you were a freelancer you know you
started doing that stuff is that is that
is that your advice if if you're trying
to transition out go ahead and start
building things start doing things sort
of showing stuff I can take that
question I think there's so the question
is you know for the transition is the
best thing to do just start working
sometimes yes but sometimes I think in
Ethan's case that the barrier to entry
might be a little too high to just start
working I would have sucked
yeah I mean when I when I did my my
startup I really didn't know what I was
doing so I spent some time with with API
documentation and tried to figure it out
and I got something sort of functional
but sometimes formal training helps
actually it and it depends on the the
field actually there's there are things
that I felt comfortable just jumping
right in and doing like like Python was
really easy for me and I didn't really
feel like I needed any formal training
to start doing pseudo professional or
professional work with Python but the in
data science occasionally we come across
calculus and I was not comfortable just
winging the calculus that that didn't
turn out so well so I also spend some
time with Khan Academy to get some of
that training to get up to speed so it
really depends on your level of comfort
and how well you know the field that
you're making the transition into I
think I think it also talen to that that
there there may be a time when it's not
a good idea to put up portfolio stuff
that you're working right now because
it's not going to help you like when I
was first getting into ml that probably
don't have been a very useful path to go
down but the the act of of doing that
work even if you're not gonna share it
with anybody I think is invaluable
because there is sort of a difference
between us
a folded track we're sort of given
something that that you need to complete
and it sort of has a lot of steps light
out for you and something where you just
come across a problem and have to figure
out how to tackle it yourself and even
if you're not sharing it necessarily I
think that that exercises some of the
most invaluable work that fills in your
ability to take an interview question or
a real project at work and produce
something valuable out of it because if
you've only ever done formal tasks that
have a lot of scaffolding and a lot of
skeleton when they're given to you then
that can be a really big blank canvas
problem of like not even knowing where
to start so it's it's just good practice
Thanks
anything any friend one I think we have
time for like one more short question
and if not we will let you guys out a
minute early okay oh yeah question
okay my question is relative to
education so there seems to be a push or
a shift to not do this delayed formal
educational track which has some
sometimes delay from progressive
financial gains or something and do you
would you recommend young this young
generation to move forward in that
direction or just cut through all of
these layers and just begin finding
yourself in the work in the workplace
niche especially with the the level of
transition and technology it doesn't
make sense to go to this formal training
and technologies changing all the time
ai is taking over the the creative
thought process all of those things that
question yes because I used to be a
professor so I have some value in
traditional education I think I I think
it depends on how you approach
traditional education if you approach it
with the question of you just want to
get a job you just want to get job
skills four-year universities are
actually pretty bad at that I I think
they are valuable in other ways like in
in this I mean I used to teach
philosophy so I'm gonna say philosophy
is fantastic but if you look at
philosophy graduate students they they
tend to perform
really well on things like the GREs on
standardized tests they do really well
in law school they like I have friends
who also are philosophers you throw them
in front of any kind of problem and
they're usually comfortable figuring it
out
and that's a that's a very valuable
skill that if you have the time and
resources to to spend time on it I think
it's it's very useful having said that
it can be a very substantial investment
that not everyone can necessarily make
and there are realities that people have
to face sometimes that I don't begrudge
anybody for focusing maybe on finding
work more immediately and doing less
formal sort of self-training in these
areas I I have three kids and I am
telling them and will continue to tell
them that a lot of education be really
valuable but youyou shouldn't jump into
a big investment like that without
knowing what it is that you expect to
get out the other side because I think
that a lot of times we've sort of really
pushed on the use need to go to college
because that's what you do and you know
if everyone goes to college and it
action doesn't have that same the same
differentiating value anymore it's just
now everyone's going to college like
it's I I think that I I'm telling them
that education is valuable and as long
as you know what it is that you want to
do and that that is why you're doing it
like that you're making an explicit
trade off rather than just one out of
out of habit or momentum that it can be
good but without doing I think that a
lot of times we make those decisions as
young people without really doing any
sort of analysis ed it's just when
everyone else is doing
I would advise not making any decision
just because it seems like it's what
everyone else is doing and I think
that's probably a question that we could
continue to talk about because there's a
lot of weight behind that but
unfortunately we're out of time for
today so I'm gonna have to wrap it up
but if anybody has anything else they'd
like to talk about come and find us
today I would be happy to continue
anything or find me on LinkedIn send me
an email etc but thank you all for
coming I really appreciate it and have a
great rest of your intersect day so
thanks guys
[Applause]